Eric is with us in Fredericksburg and
Frederick Maryland hi Eric how are you
good day sir it's an honor to speak with
you
you too sir how can I help I have a
question I'm a baby step one I'm in
Financial Peace University awesome class
learning a lot my point is I I have a
car that I have a lien on it and I'm
trying to sell that one and I got myself
a beater like you said and and and and
your baby steps and all that but my
thing is every time I try to sell the
car I've had seven serious fires for it
but when I saw my had a lien on it it's
like they get scared and just walk away
I don't know if I should keep the beater
I've invested I think a little too much
than what I expected but it was I think
I was far more excited getting on your
program than really thinking about it
and doing painting this car off well I
think what you need to do is find out
what the process is in the state of
Maryland most states it's very normal to
sell a car with lien on it that should
not spook a buyer it does all the time
though I explained to them it takes
about two to three weeks for the title
to get released and I think that's where
everybody gets gnorga there I mean
that's normally you gives you give them
the car you give them the keys you give
them a little sale and they drive away
that's normal if they get spooked on
that I just don't know how to buy a car
I mean I've done it a hundred times it's
just there's not that much to it I can't
you know you just haven't found a buyer
yet that's all it is
but again double-check and make sure
that that's the proper way to do it in
the state of Maryland and find out from
your lender how quick you can get the
title it sounds like you've already
verified that to be about two weeks
maybe you can get it in-house and the
you know you can take them over to the
bank and the title sitting there and the
bankers on the bankers desk and you know
we can just do the deal right there and
you don't have to wait on it maybe you
can work that out that way you don't let
these fish off the hook again but I
think there's something else going on
if lots of people buy cars with them
with liens on them lots of people
happens all the time
and so I would not I wouldn't sweat that
a bit